the federal reserve has been under fire
recently for owning securities that the
central bank bought during the coveted
pandemic now we are not talking about
the federal reserve itself we're talking
about members of the fed who literally
own stocks and uh or bonds and then the
fed came in and was buying some of the
assets that those individuals owned now
each person is different uh as part of
this but if you think about
the general premise here or the
framework for going through this
if i as an individual am in charge of
monetary policy decisions and i am in
charge of making decisions whether i'm
actually the decision maker or i have an
influence in the decision
of what we should be buying what we
should not be buying etc if i own assets
i obviously cannot be unbiased
so if i want to buy the assets that i
already own using somebody else's money
the fed's money then that could be
problematic i also by the way could be
problematic if i say hey rather than buy
the assets i own maybe we should divert
money somewhere else again that could be
problematic as well so it's not just
bias of hey i should go and buy the
things that i own uh you influence
decision making in either direction
which is part of the problem so what is
the solution forget complaining for a
second obviously this happens in many
industries happens with journalists it
happens with uh people in positions of
power it happens with uh politicians
elected officials etc so this is not a
new problem how you solve it is uh the
real question here and so what we know
as of today what i would consider fact
or what has come out is that fed
officials have been trading stocks and
bonds that could be influenced at least
indirectly by their policy decisions so
it's not a question of were they buying
or selling stocks that's that i think at
this point is everyone agrees like that
has been happening uh the problem is
what stocks were they buying how much
was that influenced by policy decisions
et cetera and then some people want to
start tightening the policy but others
want to wait of course there's
controversy around this or debate around
this uh probably more so than
controversy
and so if you think about uh if you're
the leader of the federal reserve what
should you do or what can you do well
what we've seen is jerome powell has
ordered a review of uh the rules the
ethics for the central bank as people
have started to say wait a minute hold
on that doesn't seem like that's cool
that the officials own stock but then
they are also uh uh influencing the
policy decisions and so what we have is
a uh cnbc article great great work by
our outsourced research partner cnbc
and what they've said is that none of
the holdings or transactions appeared to
violate the fed's code of conduct so
nobody is alleging at least from what i
understand today that there's actually
been a violation of the code of conduct
but there are questions about the fed's
conflict of interest policies and the
oversight of central bank officials so
what exactly does that mean it means
that nobody is claiming hey you broke
the rules but a lot of people are saying
maybe the current rules shouldn't be the
rules so what we do know according to
this article is that jerome powell held
between 1.25 and 2.5 million dollars of
municipal bonds they were just a small
portion of his total reported assets
he's really really rich so this is
actually a small amount while the bonds
were purchased before 2019 so way before
the pandemic they were held while the
fed last year bought more than five
billion dollars in the muni bonds
including one from the state of illinois
which was purchased by his family trust
in 2016. so let's stop here time out
jerome powell first two important things
one is uh my understanding of kind of
doing all this research with the best
business show research team the best in
the world is jerome powell has a family
trust and that family trust he is not
the one that's actually making the
decisions right and again you can debate
is he making the decisions is he not
does he have influences he's not
whatever people will figure that out but
as it stands
according to the current uh kind of
structure is there's a family trust he
is not the sole decision maker he is not
the one who's saying buy this sell this
buy this and so on top of that most of
the assets that are in question i put
that in air quotes because some people
think there are questions people don't
or things that were bought before the
pandemic so when it comes to jerome
powell right i a lot of people like to
give him a lot of [ __ ] we've definitely
questioned some of the decisions he's
made here but i think it is uh important
to also call out i don't actually think
that he's doing anything from what we
know today that seems to be uh out of
bounds right there's a bunch of assets
that they previously bought they held
hey if you're a long-term holder of
assets then of course you're going to
hold the assets regardless of if it goes
up or down kind of just good investing
principles
but also on top of that it's inside of
family trust which of he is not the
decision maker now with that said if he
knows that hey i have municipal bonds in
my family trust and yes i didn't make
the decision to buy them during the
pandemic but guess what if we go and we
buy it with fed money could it actually
prop it up absolutely and so ultimately
it gets to the point of if you're not
making the decisions in real time if
you're not actually the one making the
investment decisions and these are
assets you already held the only other
thing you could ask him to do in this
situation is not to have the assets it's
to literally just hold cash or to hold
some sort of like index fund or mutual
fund or something like that so this
seems to me like jerome powell has set
himself up in the best possible place uh
outside of simply having no investments
now i don't think that uh we should
punish people for getting into these
positions and say you can't have any
investments but i think that this is
actually probably the best structure
that we've seen so far given what we
know today now on to the next person the
boston fed president eric rosengren uh
he held between 150 000 and 800 000
worth of real estate investment trust
that owned mortgage-backed securities
this is the part that gets a little
crazy he made as many as 37 separate
trades in the four reads while the fed
purchased almost 700 billion dollars in
mortgage-backed securities now
going back to jerome powell comparing
these two jerome powell is allegedly not
the one making investment decisions we
have no reason to believe that he's
actually day trading this stuff or
making kind of frequent trades
eric rosengren
37 trades is a lot uh in terms of if
you're trading in and out of four reits
that hold the assets of which the fed is
literally putting hundreds of billions
of dollars into again we start to get a
little bit more into the slippery slope
here around uh what is okay what is not
okay how much of those trades would not
have happened if he wasn't there as uh
uh in that position how many of the
trades
would he have done that he ended up not
doing because he says in the position
maybe he actually historically did 100
trades during this time frame and now he
only did 37 so he's actually brought
down his trading there's a lot of
context missing but again i think people
get really uneasy when they see somebody
doing 37 trades
of assets that the fed is pouring so
much capital into so let's keep going
the richmond fed president thomas barkin
he held between 1.35 million and uh 3
million dollars in individual corporate
bonds purchased before 2020 before the
pandemic they include bonds of pepsi
home depot eli lilly and the fed last
year opened a corporate bond buying
facility and purchased 46 billion
dollars of corporate bonds now here is
what i end up thinking about
one if you already held the assets
it ends up being a lot less uh uh kind
of concerning right if you bought the
assets before the pandemic okay maybe
that's fair maybe that's not but i just
think psychologically people are like
okay you already held this thing you
didn't make any different investment
decision uh and so it is what it is
if you're actively trading
during the pandemic
nobody can fault an individual investor
for doing that that's how you end up
uh reacting to the market but the
problem is that when you're doing that
and also having an influence in policy
decisions that's where people get uneasy
so i think that all of the assets that
were previously bought most people are
eventually just gonna say ah they
already held the assets not a problem on
top of that if there's some sort of
family trust uh or some sort of arms
length type uh mechanism again it may
not be perfect some people may have
concerns about it but it is better than
literally me going into like an e-trade
account and like firing off day trades
right so obviously uh having some sort
of at least appearance of distance
between the policy maker and the assets
they own makes it much better
i think the big thing that people end up
getting really really worked up about is
when they see folks actually day trading
right or or frequently trading assets
that also the fed is buying at the same
time that to me feels like they're like
ah i don't know if that's really what we
want our policy officials doing yeah
when you break this down right jerome
powell if if he does have a trust and if
he can't um if he doesn't make any
investment decisions on that trust
that's totally fine um but as we said
before no one is unbiased right they may
not of let this influence their
decisions on what they do with the
policy and they may not have even
thought about their own financial
situation gain loss whatever it may have
been but
look they they know in their own mind
what they own what they don't own and
they're making decisions that both
affect themselves and our nation um
financially so we're gonna see but yeah
obviously actively making trades while
you're kind of deciding what to do uh is
is a pretty big red flag the first quote
we have here is from joseph
la
i apologize i'm probably saying it
incorrectly it's the chief economist for
the americas at nattix's joseph said
quote the ethics here look bad they
should have known better once you lose
that moral authority it's a problem i
think it's a very very good point which
is regardless of if you're actually
doing something wrong or not the
appearance of it is much more important
in almost one in some way because
everyone historically has thought of
these institutions as having that moral
authority they're always trying to do
the right thing they may not always be
right but they're always acting in good
faith they're always doing the right
thing if you lose the moral authority
that's where very quickly the confidence
game gets shot there's trust that
unwinds and like that and we can kind of
spiral into a bad place pretty quickly
yeah well it's a credibility thing right
so once you lose that uh credibility
with the public and with other officials
and authoritative figures it becomes a
really really big problem and
look it uh it's it's sad but you also
get more scrutinized after the fact
right so then every decision you make
from there on out is heavily scrutinized
because they know you've done something
wrong in the past uh whether it's true
or not it's a credibility issue
the next quote that we have here comes
from christopher whalen the chairman of
weyland global advisors i appreciate you
christopher made this real simple for me
he said quote keep in mind they already
have trading rules they imposed on banks
for example and yet the fed's governors
don't live by those same rules after
dodd-frank the post-crisis banking
reforms every agency in washington
tightened up little conflicts like
insider trading yet the fed is somehow
exempt from those rules they look
ridiculous now we're getting a little
bit more spicy with what people are
saying here i think this is a very fair
point as well so one is once you lose
the moral authority there it becomes a
problem second is if all of a sudden
there's a ton of rules that everyone
else in the industry has to operate
alongside uh or um abide by but you as
the policymaker don't have to do it
again they look ridiculous right that
not my words his words but i think that
that is the sentiment people say wait a
second hold on after 2008 2009 all these
other organizations tightened it up they
said hey look maybe we shouldn't allow
people to do abrc things but the fed
didn't do that and so that's where
people are saying uh i think that this
is a problem and so my guess is if they
move and they make rule changes
regardless of how severe the rule
changes are people will say okay at
least they're headed in the right
direction they may not like the rule of
changes they may not think they're
aggressive enough but at least they feel
like hey the fed is listening they're
actually changing stuff but i think this
is a very fair point where people say
look if all of a sudden that other
people are having to live by these new
rules and every other agency in
washington tightened up little conflicts
like insider trading side note the fact
that we're calling insider trading
little conflicts is pretty crazy to me
like maybe it's a big conflict of your
insider trading um but the uh the point
here about the fed is somehow exempt
from those rules doesn't actually sit
well with people and so i think they're
gonna have to end up making some changes
here right
yeah i agree look the problem is and we
were talking about the solution earlier
is that like what do you do and one of
the solutions is well maybe they can't
own stocks or bonds directly in um the
sectors that they kind of regulate but
that's not really a viable solution as
you want to be able to have uh you want
them to be able to like
own anything really right um but look
it's unbiased it's no matter what
they're in a bad situation um no matter
what uh decision they make and
investments they buy they're gonna be
scrutinized no matter what uh last quote
we have is from dennis keller the ceo of
better markets said quote to think that
such trading is acceptable because it is
supposedly allowed by the fed's current
policy only highlights that the fed's
policies are woefully deficient should
people at the federal reserve not be
allowed to hold assets outside of
low-cost index funds indoors mutual fund
types things where they basically are
just buying baskets they're not picking
individual securities they're not
picking uh individual bonds they're not
able to pick individual commodities it's
more of you can get broad-based exposure
to the market but part of your duty in
serving in this role and having the
privilege of serving in this appointed
role is to
give up some of the economic upside that
you could gain by playing the markets
and investing in other assets agreed
it's also their code of conduct is a
little vague right so i want to read an
expert from it that says
they should be careful to avoid any
dealings or other conduct that might
convey even an appearance of conflict
between their personal interests the
interest of the system and then and the
public interest right so it is a little
vague it's basically like hey don't do
anything unethical right that's what a
code of conduct is so
it's like they're in a bad situation i
don't think that we should
financially harm people or not let them
own certain stocks because they're
making policy decisions on those stocks
but you just have to it has to be
watched very very carefully so if you
look at the federal reserve board
salaries according to glassdoor
again could be a little off but
directionally probably correct
economists get paid base pay 167
thousand dollars with
about 25 000 of additional pay so they
come in right below 200 000 or so total
pay
a research assistant can get paid about
65 70 000
a year a senior research assistant could
get paid a little bit more kind of 75
000 or so interns 25 bucks an hour funny
how they pay their interns 25 an hour uh
if we look at somebody like let's say a
senior economist they get paid about 190
to 200 000 a year plus with additional
pay comes in around 225 230 and then
when you look at somebody in the it uh
spot that's an intern they get paid 26
an hour so you get one dollar extra an
hour if you're a regular intern versus
the it uh but even managers at the fed
are getting paid 160 thousand 170 000
with the potential to earn up to uh
almost 200 thousand dollars so there are
uh for the staff
there are very high uh um kind of uh
salaries but the that doesn't include
the people actually uh who are on the uh
thing so if we look real quick if we
look at let's say jerome powell's salary
uh he is chair of the federal federal
reserve it's only two hundred thousand
dollars right so it's not like it's a
ton of money
if you said to me instead of allowing
them to play in markets just go pay a
million bucks a year pay them two
million dollars a year fine like we just
printed five trillion like we got the
cash right just literally go
everybody who is a fed president payment
two and a half million dollars a year
five million dollars a year like pay
them whatever we need so that they're
not out there yoloing in the markets
making all these day trades and and uh
uh kind of periodic trading so that we
can try to get to some semblance of not
having influence and bias in their
policy decision what's up guys bang bang
a bunch of you want to bring that
trillionaire energy every day and if you
want to do it in your financial life go
use sofi sofa is our exclusive sponsor
because we think they've got a great
piece of software that'll help you
accomplish your financial dreams go to
sofi.com today to get started you can
invest in everything from etfs to
individual stocks to cryptocurrencies to
ipos and they even have an automated and
best function head on over to sofi.com
pomp today and make sure you come back
tomorrow to watch more of the best
business show
[Music]
you